A man that weighs 175 pounds should have 35 milligrams of the drug. Great
solving if you figured that out. If the proportion gave you a little bit of
trouble, let's see how we can set it up together. Because the amount of medicine
varies directly with the person's weight, we want to set up this proportion, the
amount of medicine or the dosage for the first case Would be directly across
from the weight from the first case. 30 milligrams is prescribed for someone who
weighs 150 pounds. So this would be the first numbers for our first case. We
don't know how much of the drug should be prescribed for a man that weigh 175
pounds. So the amount of the drug, or the amount of medicine 2 is unknown, it's
x. But the corresponding weight for that drug dosage is 175 pounds. So we put
that here. Finally we cross multiply and then divide both sides by 150. This
leaves us with x is equal to 35. Now I really think it's important to make sense
of our reason through this answer. Should this be more or less than the 30
milligrams originally? Well we said the amount of medicine varied directly. So
that means if the drug dosage increases, the weight increases as well. We know
the weight increased from 150 pounds to 175 pounds. So it'd make sense that our
drug increased from 30 milligrams to 35 milligrams. If anything, we can just be
sure that the second amount is higher, or greater than, the first amount.